quand le PACS a été voté tout s'est fait
très vite manuel et Olivier vivaient
ensemble depuis deux ans ils avaient
envie de légaliser leur union mais pour
la beauté et la force du symbole pas
pour les avantages qu'elle est avec car
dans les faits leur statut de PACS
si j'ai une mutuelle obligatoire et j'ai
pu prendre manuel avec moi
les avantages que le que le PACS donc on
a économisé 2000 francs de mutuelle par
an plus tard quand leur pack sera 3 ans
ils pourront aussi éventuellement
décider de faire une déclaration de
revenus communs mais pour le reste la
loi ne présente que très peu de
bénéfices concrets pour beaucoup de
lourdeurs et d'imprécisions la volonté
délibérée de ne pas pouvoir prêter le
flanc à une quelconque comparaison avec
le mariage a abouti à un choix qui
n'était certainement pas le meilleur
juridiquement parlant notamment dès que
des biens sont en jeu alors que les
couples mariés ont le choix entre un
régime de communauté ou de séparation de
bien le régime de l'indivision par
défaut s'impose au pacsé tous les biens
qui par l'un ou l'autre pendant le PACS
meuble voiture ou actions sont supposés
appartenir aux deux même sans volonté
explicite de leur part et c'est là où
commence les litiges en cas de rupture
de PACS la séparation comme celle que
vit cet homme peut alors être très mal
vécu alors comme vous voyez la penderie
était à lui donc il l'a remporté à
l'aide d'un huissier qui est venu
estimer que c'était à lui
et tout ce que contient cet appartement
est aujourd'hui objet de conflit entre
les deux hommes nous avons été pacsés
pendant effectivement à peu près trois
mois et la fin difficile
c'est donc une histoire d'amour qui
finit mal avec en prime un flux
juridique qui est venu me la situation
alors qu'ils étaient encore pacsés
Frédéric et son ami ont acheté une
voiture et il est parti avec donc il a
déposé plainte pour le vol des clés donc
en fait la voiture d'après mon avocat
elle nous appartient à tous les deux
donc ce serait plutôt moi qui devrait
réclamer la voiture une semaine sur deux
ou un jour sur deux ou il y a un grand
flou d'autant que l'assurance était à
mon nom la carte grise au sien donc
c'est vrai que c'est assez
Frédéric Ferrier n'est pas pour autant
dégouté du PACS les couples homosexuels
n'ont pas d'autre choix pour entériner
leur union mais la prochaine fois il
s'assurera de faire préciser chaque
point du contrat par un notaire à moins
que d'ici là la loi n'était évoluée